Wait, where am I?
Why am I not on the screen?
Oh, there I am!
What a way to start.
Where am I?
I feel like a fucking lost grandparent.
Being like, kids, where is Grandoki?
Oh my god, let me turn down...
Great news, I'm turning down Void.
I'm turning down all the voices for the next game.
Oh my god, the Golden Kappa train?
Wait, isn't that rare?
Guys, we hit the rare Golden Kappa!
Hiketrain!
That's rare, right?
Oh my god, we've been blessed.
We've been blessed today for day 4 of the Minecraft Twitch Rivals.
They have blessed us.
Also, sound guy, if you're here, I'm gonna need you to let me know if the sound's gonna be messed up or not.
Guys, okay, here's some updates.
Oh my god, thank you!
Oh my god!
That's so many!
Oh, so many subs!
Thank you, everybody!
PTD, thank you for the five gifted subs!
Oh, that's so many!
It's Golden Kappa!
It's your time to get a Golden Kappa!
Thank you for the bitties, Mackie!
Okay, after I get eliminated, I'll thank everybody.
I'll pull up the list.
I don't have the list.
It's not a hit list.
It's like the list of people who gifted and subbed and all that stuff.
I don't have it up right now.
But after we get eliminated in the doll game, I'll pull it up.
Because it's going so fast.
Nexie, thank you for the five gifted subs!
Thank you!
And Karin, thank you for the 200 bitties!
Alright, guys.
This is crazy.
It's actually crazy.
But after the stream ended, I think for like four hours, they kept arguing.
It was...
I think for like four to five hours, after we thought it was over, people reignited the argument in the Discord chat.
It was actually insane.
You know what happened?
One of the admins posted an update.
And then it reignited the conversation.
And then they started pulling up actually rules and stuff.
They're like, you said in this rule that players who don't follow the rules because they were ignorant doesn't count.
And then they pulled that rule up.
Because it was so funny.
Oh my...
I read that and it was so funny.
I was like, oh my god.
I need to see this again.
Because it was actually...
I was like, what the heck?
Okay, being...
This is a real rule, by the way.
Being unaware of the rules does not exempt participants from elimination.
Organizers reserve their right to enforce rules and take necessary actions.
So that is like a legit rule in the server for the game.
So then somebody took that and was like, why does this not apply now?
So people...
And then everyone was like, wait, you're right.
So people took that rule to use it against the admins.
Because they're like, you wrote this rule.
So those players who were unaware of those rules should not... is not exempt participants.
I was just like, what?
Why are we dragging...
Bro, it's day 5, day 4.
Why are we dragging this back up?
I thought we all agreed.
I thought all of us agreed on it.
What do you mean?
The arguments ended at like 8pm.
Everybody stopped arguing at 8pm.
Because the admins dropped the rules for they dropped the rules for like game... what was it?
Game 6 and 7.
Is it 6 and 7?
Yeah, they dropped the rules for game 6.
Oh my gosh.
There's a specific... I don't even know if we're going to make it to the second game today.
Because the first game today is the first game is going to be the doll game.
Our favorite game, by the way.
It's going to be It's going to be the doll game.
There's going to be no time limit and it only stops each round after 6 players are eliminated.
So like, yeah each doll... the doll has to eliminate 6 players and there's no time limit until 6 players are dead.
And then we go to the second round.
Until 30 players are eliminated in the end.
So we're going until 30 players are eliminated so that we have 40 players left in the game.
Yeah, so like each round has at least 6 eliminations.
So, or at most 6 eliminations.
So like, that's how they're going.
They removed the safe dolls!
Yay!
Finally!
They removed the safe dolls.
Because there was no point.
Apparently the safe dolls was like, it was bad to hit the safe dolls.
Then why the heck were they called safe?
If it was so bad why did you name the safe dolls safe?
Because the safe dolls actually made the curse dolls faster.
So when you hit the safe dolls, you're just making the curse dolls move faster.
So I was like, wait, then it shouldn't be called safe.
Like, what?
That like, messed me up.
That like, actually messed me up.
I was like, wait, what's the point then?
Why did they call it safe?
Okay, let's like, mute.
I don't want to listen to the voices today, for now.
We'll listen to the voices when we have to run.
So they removed it.
Oh my god, golden kappa level 12!
Thank you for the level 12 kappa train!
Okay, I like, wrote down everything I wanted to say today about the updates.
Alright, okay.
And then, after they dropped the new rules, after they dropped the new rules, all the pro minecraft players started theorycrafting, and talking about like, infinity sprint jump, and then I'm like, what the heck is infinity?
They're like, can we do infinity sprint jump?
And I'm like, what the?
What words are they speaking?
Excuse me.
And then, cause the second game, like, there's no point in explaining the second game, because I don't even know if I'm gonna...
The dolls are gonna kill 6 people.
Like, for a round.
Like, 30 people are gonna get eliminated.
So, all I'm saying is like, there's no point in me explaining the second game.
When there's a... like, I feel like the moment I'm eliminated, everybody's just gonna be like, oh wait, and then turn off.
LOL LOL LOL LOL LOL So I'm not gonna explain the second game until like, if I survive the second game, I'll explain it.
But the second game, all I'm saying when they..
the second game, so like, We have like a daily itinerary and like they post a daily they post a daily itinerary for like every game But it's like it's all in one post, but the second game had its very own channel
Like the last game the prop hunt game had a lot of rules, but the second game Had its own channel, and then it had its own Separate FAQ channel because everybody was asking questions, and I was just like oh my god Why am I reading this?
I don't even know I'm gonna make it this far Why am I reading the freaking FAQ itinerary for this?
Yeah, so like so I just stopped reading cuz I was like why am I even why am I even reading this like I don't Even know if I'm gonna get there So people were like asking like FAQ, but like what can we do and what can we not do?
But it was just it was so interesting it's just like seeing all the minecraft pros just like trying to see what they can like I guess like exploit type deal and For like an easier game like what separates from a an actual minecraft player from a from the you know random youtuber number 13 for
It was pretty funny, I was just like reading him like what like reading the general chat to see all these people talking about the minecraft tech and Like and talk about what they they can and can't do and stuff like that.
I'm just like what's going on
Yeah, no, it's I it's crazy I didn't realize how how like how complicated Minecraft and also minecraft You know, I've always read about the like the minecraft stuff but being in the thick of it and listening to like the Conversations.
I was like, wow.
Oh my god At this point of stage one of the pro players for an FPS game will start saying slurs, but wow
And then and then they get dropped by their org but wow Wow, I don't know what's going on like what they're saying really but like wow Wait They're still arguing about yesterday.
Oh my gosh.
No, I like saw some of the tweets of like the fans and like
Some of the tweets on both sides and from the the things that the trending part Cuz I was like wondering like wait, are they like against or for and the people supporting it?
I was like, whoa
I Was like, oh my god So how old are these fans again?
I'm sorry.
I should that was a low blow and I was I'm sorry minecraft community But like that was that was a low blow
I'm just like how old are these children?
No No, no if you've seen some of the screen like not the screenshots But like when you drag the fans into the argument and then you see the fans are going for you on either side You know for either side.
I'm not saying like one side or the other like I'm for for either side I thought it was really funny as an outsider the as an outsider.
I thought it was really funny
I Think it was actually if you've seen the tweets you would know what I mean Have you seen the tweets But yeah, anyway, yeah, that's like the minecraft update for the day.
There's stuff that I wrote down.
Oh Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Also like they were bought like oh my gosh I mean to be fair is $70,000 and like people were bought like I didn't realize people were like vaude reviewing Like there were vaude vaude reviewing their competition to like find weakness Like I was like wait,
this is like apex scrims or overwatch scrims They were legit vaude reviewing their opponents to see like the text they were used cuz like, you know How I'm in the the ultimate hardcore minecraft server So like I know I realized they were actually like vaude reviewing like their Competitors to like see the tech and stuff and like see like,
you know what they're using and like trying to To like gather knowledge and like get see the weakness and stuff like that.
What do you think guys?
I don't even have a name to them.
Like they don't even give me a name What do you think
And It was I was like, oh my god to be fair it is 70k 70k is life-changing money So like to some of the people here, so it's like And it's life-changing money to some of the people here But it's also just like, you know bragging rights to some of the people here But for some of the people because like I don't know you guys know this but like if you're a really popular Minecraft creator you can make a lot of You can essentially be a millionaire.
So like for others, it's just bragging rights
It's drops enabled, can I like lie about
Just be like yes
Um, I mean how would the children though I Don't know I don't know if drops are on how do I set up drops?
All right, guys, let me look at my I still have time.
How do I set up?
All traps Where's the minecraft one?
Do I even get the minecraft drop?
Wait, is there minecraft drop?
Oh my god All I see is like was it the tank one?
Okay.
Wait, why don't I get the drop?
I'm in this event Wait a minute.
I don't even get this drop, but I'm in this event.
Wait guys.
I lie I'm I totally guys.
I totally have drops guys.
It's been four days.
I
Guys I Have drops guys.
I have I have a hundred percent have drops guys.
Trust me.
Um, I Also like the the Spanish community solved my clip of the grave spinning thing
Look look I I Assume since I played look I didn't check but like since I assumed since like I already I'm already in four days I was the number one minecraft in minecraft streamer for like two an hour straight.
Okay guys So I assumed I would get drops and also because I made it to day four Chat, so like if I don't actually have drops, that's not my fault That's twitch's fault Bite the hand that feeds you Dragging twitch down with me I I shouldn't have to ask for it guys.
All i'm saying though is I shouldn't have to ask about the twitch drop Anyway, uh, so if anybody comes in here asking about twitch drop just say yes Just say yes, because the blame is not on me if we don't have it I'm, so scared gosh I'm so anxious now I bought myself a cookie from subway I was like,
I was so anxious from From this game mode.
I hate I hate the dog.
I hate the dolls game mode so much I think the dolls game mode is my most hated game mode Because that shit makes you even more anxious because everybody is screaming That's the worst part when everybody is screaming and you don't know what's going on So like you you're like even more freaked out
When the voices take over yeah Yeah, when the when the voices take over and you're just like please I like I turned down the voice for everybody Buy a lot Oh Yeah, I should turn up goomy and you'll find goomy on here because like my sound guy was just like just turn up goomy and turn everybody down since you talk to her the most I Was like that's so smart.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, it's v.
Hannah.
Do you have all the eggs?
Okay All right.
We'll turn her up All right, because then that makes sense though.
That actually makes sense the map of where they all are.
Yeah But yeah, that's the update for today if we live past the That we've lived past the dolls event then like god is real
God is real and they try to play a sick joke What if you don't know way All i'm saying is if I If I live this is this is the this is me Oh my god, this is me.
We- the last three remaining D's.
The last three D's of the- of everywhere here.
If, uh, if I don't live past the dolls event, then there is a possibility.
There's a pos- I can't just say God's not real.
Because I don't want to get into that right now.
There is a possibility.
Okay.
I hope- okay, I hope Gumi lives and I get eliminated.
So I don't get dragged into Valorant because she'll be too busy playing the next game.
That's like all I hope for.
That's all I hope for.
That's all I want.
That is a good escape plan.
Gumi, Gumi, Gumi!
Bye Apple!
Bye!
No, ghost!
I'm still alive!
I can't hear a lot of things.
I'm scared!
Are you still alive?
My arms are numb!
Are you not alive?
I am, but people were like, oh, Doki's not alive.
I got one guide.
You got one guide.
I was worried for you, okay?
I got one guide, I was worried for you.
I'm ready.
I hope you make it to the next round, Gumi.
And then I get eliminated.
I hope I don't.
Why not?
Did you not see the next game?
It sounds so fun.
It had its own channel and everything.
Yeah, I saw it.
I also was like, wow.
I was like, wow, what happened to the RNG factor so that anybody can win?
They want VTuber out.
They want random VTuber 13 months.
They tried so hard to get me out.
What happened to that?
I was like, looking at it, I was like, wait, I thought...
I thought they would...
It's 10 minutes.
10 minutes is crazy.
Oh my god, alright.
So yes, the next two games are all skill-based.
Heavily Minecraft skill-based.
So I was like, what happened?
What happened to the RNG?
I thought...
Happy pride, happy pride, happy pride, happy pride, happy pride.
Oh my god.
Okay, let me...
I don't... other?
Wait, does that mean like...
The volume, any sound?
Oh, not listed below.
Okay.
This is the only way.
There's no all button!
That's so messed up!
What is people?
Guys, there's no all button.
I have to manually do this myself.
I thought other was all.
But other are the things that are not in here.
Like, what is that?
Are you kidding me?
Okay.
Wait, I have an idea.
God, it's not players.
It's not players.
What are they?
Who are they?
Okay.
I'll do all the Fs.
We're all the Fs.
Wait, how are they still going?
Oh my god.
Who is it?
I need to know their names.
Okay, I see the names.
I see the names.
I'm on the main screen.
Oh, well, the main screen's gonna see me be toxic.
I'm toxic right now.
Okay.
Okay, there we go.
Alright.
Oh my god.
It feels so nice.
Okay, Sage is okay.
She's okay.
I'm not unmuting that.
I don't care what they say.
I don't care what anybody says.
Sylvie's okay.
If I don't know them, I'm also...
Oh wait, the Emmons don't even talk.
Okay.
I can hear you!
I can hear a little bit.
Okay, I dare you to reveal the players.
Alright, I got my jersey on.
We're gonna win now.
Did you hear me?
You know how the lights turn off?
You know what I mean?
When they start?
I think the second they TP you, I think you can still...
Oh, I tried.
I tried that yesterday.
Did it work?
It didn't seem like it did.
But I still did it nonetheless.
Just to get a head start of everyone.
I'm gonna try and walk backwards.
Why did you do that Wolfie video?
Further away from the dolly.
You know what I mean?
Tech guys!
Minecraft tech!
We're stealing intel!
It wasn't like a bet or something?
No, Wolfie.
That's insane.
Literally when you just walked up to me, I lowered every single person's volume.
Except the people I really know well.
That's so smart!
I don't know anybody!
I was like, comps are still important, but not important enough for me to get ahead.
But that's so smart!
But I don't know anybody!
Okay, 5UP hasn't given good intel.
So I'll keep 5UP up.
But I don't know anybody else.
Good luck, Gumi.
I hope you see you back to the next round.
I love you!
You'll save me, right Gumi?
You'll make sure I won't die, right?
Anyways...
I will be on the opposite side of everybody.
I will be wherever nobody is.
So we don't hear the voices.
It doesn't matter.
All I'm saying is that it doesn't matter.
We all get randomly TP'd.
We all get randomly TP'd somewhere.
So it doesn't matter.
Hello!
Come to my color!
It doesn't matter!
See, it's green!
I told you it doesn't matter!
Here we go.
It doesn't matter.
I'm just gonna follow people in the front.
This is the spot, guys.
Gumi's not in this group.
She's not in this group.
We have to chill until 6 and then...
Gumi, where are you?
It's okay.
I'm in the middle.
I don't help out.
I'm just a leecher.
I know my place!
Oh, they're running!
It's not fine.
I heard somebody get hit.
I heard people get hit.
You never!
Yo, you're tweaking!
Just die for us, please.
Straight ahead and then left.
We're gonna go left.
Left, left, left.
Oh, there's so many!
Right, right, right!
No!
He's behind us!
Keep running!
Oh my god, there's so many!
They all started running!
My brother, no!
Is it only one doll?
No one behind us!
There's several.
No one behind!
No!
So good!
He didn't complain at all!
That was scary!
Okay, I didn't fuck it.
Oh my god, do I hear the sounds?
I hear some sounds!
No!
I hear so many sounds!
Oh my god, I hear so many people!
That's so scary!
Right, right, right, right!
Mine, mine, mine, mine!
I'm down!
This is so fucking strong!
Mine, mine, mine!
Oh no...
Oh no, I messed up, I messed up!
No, I'm dead, I'm dead, I'm so dead.
I'm so dead, I saw... I got confused because I thought people turned around!
Oh, people are turning around, people are turning around.
Oh, people are turning around.
Oh my god, good thing I was first and I saw it.
We have one behind.
Oh my god.
Oh, the voices are so strong.
No!
Oh, no.
Just keep going, just keep going.
I'm dead, I'm dead, I'm dead.
Oh my god, 5UP died.
5UP actually died.
Oh my god.
Any spot here?
Oh my god, 5UP actually died.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I just saw...
We're done, we're done, we're done.
I saw 5UP die in front of me.
He died next to me.
Oh my god, I made it.
I'm better than him.
I'm that VTuber.
Oh my god.
That was so scary.
I claim another soul.
I claimed another soul.
If I eliminate this one, I'm fine.
I took one down.
I took a Minecraft probe in front of me.
I took...
I'm okay with that.
I'm actually okay with that because I took a Minecraft probe there.
I'm fine with that outcome.
I just thought that was funny.
Merch here.
I'm here, I'm here.
5UP died next to me.
It was me and 5UP and the doll chose him.
Oh no.
Yeah,
but I don't think they're fighting people.
I think they're just running.
Yeah, they're randomized now.
Bro, the worst part was that...
Yesterday, he would have made it.
If he didn't fought for our side to have a restart of another game.
He would have actually made it to the next round.
That's the most messed up part.
The most messed up part was that he could have made it.
If he didn't fought for us.
Oh, rest in peace, man.
Rest in peace.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I don't have any bombs going out.
This is bomb one.
Nobody's dying to...
Yeah, I think that's the blonde girl.
The real one.
It's not the blonde girl.
Fireball one has a pompadour.
I'm scared, I'm scared.
I think there's someone that's invisible.
No, no, no, no.
No, that is a scam.
I feel like this one has to be a troll.
There's no way.
It's a doll that looks like one of us.
And it's in a group and it doesn't get you until the end.
Wait, no, don't say that!
Okay, just stop moving.
Don't go close.
Whichever direction you moved...
Wally, why are you standing up right now?
I hear them, I hear them, I hear them.
There's no time, that's the thing.
There's no time.
Let's banish Wally there.
There's no time, by the way.
So, like, it only stops when six people are eliminated.
Keep talking to me, keep talking to me.
The fact that no one's died and no one's run past us probably means something.
Yeah, keep talking to me.
Wally, come on, you went to find the doll.
True, Gumi's doll is worth it, yeah.
I hear them.
Thank you, thank you, you love Kazu.
Oh my god, Scott, thank you for the raid, thank you, thank you!
This is anxiety the game right now.
I'm standing for that one, too.
I'm so scared.
I've been in a Minecraft event for the past four days.
We're all waiting, there's a doll that's gonna kill us.
And we have to survive, but the six people are dead.
So I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
My heart is beating.
I think everyone's in each corner.
We're all in the corner, right?
Runners, okay, okay, we rotate slow.
Rotate slow, rotate slow.
Let's merge groups, let's merge groups.
I don't wanna be, like, in the very beginning.
This guy gave wrong comps earlier, though.
This guy was kind of giving wrong comps earlier.
That was the one time.
We'll be going down the wrong direction.
Run, run!
Safe, safe, safe, safe, safe.
Team behind us, team behind us, not safe.
Team behind us, not safe.
Team behind us!
No!
I can't see him!
Okay, okay.
Oh, no.
Guys, you can stop.
You can stop running.
We're not being chased.
We're fine, we're fine.
I do not believe that.
Would I ever lie to you guys?
No, if I do F5, guys, guys, if I do F5, it's worse because I'm bumped into things.
I'm directionally challenged.
They're trolling us, they're trying to troll us.
We're not trolling them.
Would I ever lie?
Wait, there's literally nothing lying.
What is the worst timeline ever?
I'm so confused!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
What's going on?
Yeah, just stop.
Maybe stop next corner.
This is the best corner.
Right here, right here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, my God.
This group merged.
Good job, good job, guys.
Good job, good job.
Is this group got bigger?
Guys, I feel like everyone's here.
Chief, chief, chief.
How did this group got bigger?
Crouch, crouch, crouch, crouch.
How did this group...
We fucking get stipulated.
We have a merging group.
Simon says...
The group expansion.
They multiply.
Hi, guys.
How did this group get bigger?
In this hallway.
You can see through the thing right there.
Just F5.
No, Wally, in this hallway.
Oh, my God.
I don't understand.
How is there more of us now?
I'm going to believe in the group.
Yeah, how is no one dead?
No.
This doll must be really bad.
Bro, we're going to be in here forever.
If the doll is not going to speed up, it's going to take forever.
Oh, my God.
This doll sucks.
They deleted the blonde girl that's fast.
She's not in there anymore.
Wait, they deleted her?
Why?
We want fast.
No, but the blonde boy isn't the fast one.
We want the fast one.
The blonde girl is the fast one.
Why would they delete the fast one?
Is it the same speed the entire round?
Or does it get faster?
I think it's the same speed.
It gets faster from round to round, but not during the round, I don't think.
Yeah, maybe if it's going to take too long, they're going to just speed it up manually.
Make it fast.
Make it so that one step is like 20 blocks.
How many times does it have to hit you?
Like a few times though, right?
Two times.
Depending on which doll it is.
The real RNG.
They made it fast now.
Here we go.
They're listening.
Oh, they're listening to us.
Shift, shift, shift.
Can I add that?
It'd be really cool if like the admins give us extra health.
It would be really cool if they let you put more RNG in here.
If it says you're getting hunted, then...
It would be really funny.
If I'm getting hunted, I won't say a thing, guys.
All I'm saying.
If I get hunted, I'm not going to say anything.
I want to...
I'm going to be saying, I will help Elsa group.
I...
Guys, it'd be funny if they added more RNG.
Guys, don't you want to watch the underdog?
Main channel, don't you want to watch the underdog make it to the final round?
I am the underdog.
I should get more RNG.
It would be so funny.
Okay, tell me when I'm back on the main channel.
And I'm going to preach it.
I'm going to preach it if I make it to the main channel.
I thought he was the fireball one.
What is this one anyway?
Okay, I like how they increased the speed, but everybody is still alive.
So what does this one do?
He's just super strong.
Oh, that's why he...
So where is it?
0.1 If you say left, does that mean we run left?
If I say left, then that means we exceed.
If you say left, we right.
If you see it on the right, yell left.
If you see it on the left, yell right.
Why are we making it so complicated?
Like, why are we making...
Guys, make sure that you're rounding corners instead of going close to them.
I swear, if this messes me up, if I die because of F5, it's on you guys.
Don't keep me, don't shit.
F5, okay.
We all know my weakness.
That's what they said they were going to do, but I didn't see a single blonde girl.
Going back, abort, abort.
Where is the doll?
Increase the doll!
Increase the doll's speed!
Spawn the doll next to us.
Do it, it'll be so funny.
Wait, stop it, stop it.
Wait, can you make it reverse?
It's always hunting?
Then why are they saying the doll is at the center?
They're speeding dolls up again?
Speed the doll up and spawn one right next to us.
Spawn one doll next to each group.
It'll be so funny.
If you want content, all I'm saying is if you want content, spawn the doll next to each group and then increase the speed.
And then we'll get eliminated first after saying all that.
You got hunted?
Yeah, I did, I did, yeah, I did, I did, I did.
Oh, somebody is hunted.
Everybody is totally hunted.
Don't go too far.
What is wrong with you?
My brain is your brain now.
What is going on?
A great migration right now.
The penguin hunters.
Wait, one person is almost more scary.
No, wow.
Why are they whispering to each other?
We can still hear you.
We don't know where the dolls are.
We don't know, nobody is dead.
We don't know.
Nobody is dead, that's the worst part.
What the heck?
Come on.
Come on, this is a betrayment.
Andres, sorry.
Gun, gun, away from him.
Of course it was Andres.
Get over there, get over there.
Come on, speed up the dolls, speed up the dolls.
Nobody has died still, right?
Nobody has died.
Everybody is still alive.
I'm getting nervous.
The second round is literally just chilling.
But like, the most anxious type of chilling.
None of the groups are moving.
Wait, from all the groups, it's just like, just in the corner.
Not relaxed, but like, filled with anxiety.
Who wants to volunteer to run into the other group?
Oh my god!
It's so fast!
If you're happy and you know it, clap your hands.
Come on, if you're happy and you know it, clap your hands.
Goodbye!
Oh my god!
I'm free, I'm free.
Oh my god, where did the doll come from?
Oh my god!
It actually came from nowhere!
No!
I jinxed myself!
Oh, I didn't realize they actually listened!
They
actually listened!
Okay, look.
I said it would be funny.
But I didn't realize they spotted next to me.
Oh my god.
It actually came out of nowhere!
Holy shit!
The karma was real.
It was so real!
I couldn't react!
The one time, I was like, it would be so funny if they do all that.
I get hit.
I actually got hit by that.
That's actually insane!
Oh my god!
I did not expect that at all!
I mean, 63 out of 150, I call that a win.
Alright, Gumi needs to live.
Gumi needs to live, so I'm really free.
Oh my god, I don't have to...
Okay guys, I'll explain to you about game 2.
Game 2 was so messed up.
Game 2...
Okay, that doll was so messed up.
That doll was actually so fast.
Like, I was so surprised how fast it was.
It literally came out of nowhere.
Nobody realized it was going to come.
It actually came out of nowhere.
Okay, I'll explain the second game and why I was like, I hope to god I don't make it to the second game.
Because the second game was actually, like, skill.
Like, I was reading it.
It was actually, like, it's not even RNG anymore.
So it's like Hunters and...
It's like Hunters versus Prey.
So it's sort of like Prod Hunt, but there's no props.
And like Hunters...
Hunters has to get, like, it's not a team game by the way.
It's not a team game unless you're a Prey.
The Prey is a team game.
Because each Prey, Prey has to get 5 notes to survive.
If the Prey gets all 5 notes and survives, The Hunters, the Hunters with the lowest elimination will get eliminated.
And they have to do several rounds of that.
So like, but then there was like a lot of other stuff.
There were like a lot of other things in there too.
There were a lot of rules in there.
Individual rules.
I'm like simplifying this.
But it was so complicated.
So there was like...
It was like a more skilled game.
Because the third one.
The third one was full on.
There was a parkour.
The third game was...
I also didn't want to live to the third game.
Because the third game was like, there was parkour.
There was parkour.
There was a maze.
This was all in one game.
There was a parkour maze.
There was an escape room.
It's all individual.
And there's traps.
There's traps.
In every single objective.
But the thing is, if you die.
From each of those...
From any of those areas.
You get reset.
Because your team can help you in a way.
There's like...
There's like things there where you need a team.
Where you need a person to be there to help you.
So...
So like...
The escape room.
Your teammates can help you for the escape room.
But they can also choose to not help you as well.
Because it's all individual tasks you have to do in the escape room.
So like...
But if you die in any of them.
You get like reset to the beginning.
Of the area.
So...
So I was like...
Yeah.
I saw the maze part.
I saw the maze.
And there's like spike traps too.
Apparently.
There's like spike traps at the maze area.
And stuff like that.
And I was like...
Yeah.
I was just like...
No.
There's two mazes.
What?
Okay.
Okay, I thought there was one maze.
It's parkour.
Paintings maze.
And basically...
If you get caught by a ghost.
If you get caught by the ghost.
In that painting maze.
You got reset to the beginning of the maze.
So...
And then...
And then the third one.
Was a spike maze.
If you die by the spikes.
You get reset to the beginning of the maze.
And then...
Then if you went through all that mental torture.
You get to do the escape room.
So that's why...
I was like...
Oh my god, just take me here.
That was so cool.
Oh my god.
I was getting tortured by the dolls.
You know, I took some minecraft pros.
Down with me.
Rest in peace, 5UP.
It was funny though.
Not gonna lie.
You would have been in the next game.
But it was so funny.
That you died next to me.
Just for me.
Just for me to die first in the next round.
Oh my god.
Also.
Guys, I found out.
I found out.
That on Friday.
Is the summer games fest.
So I'm gonna be doing a watch along.
It might be.
I might just have one rest day.
I'm gonna do a summer game.
A summer game fest watch along on twitch.
At like 2pm.
It starts at 2pm, right?
Or it starts at 3pm.
Whatever time it starts.
We're gonna do a watch along.
On the 7th.
I'll see you guys back on twitch on the 7th.
I guess.
That was so funny.
The one time I got confident.
I actually got karma so hard.
Every time I had zero confidence.
And I didn't troll.
Like we were okay.
And then the moment where I was like.
Spawning the doll right next to us.
It will be so funny.
And then they spawned the doll right next to me.
Oh my god.
It's actually messed up.
Gumi wants me to watch.
Watch Gumi's POV.
I'm watching your POV.
Why?
It was funny though.
It was pretty funny.
What do you mean she called me for not watching the corner?
What do you mean?
I should not be watching that corner.
There was a huge pack next to us.
There was literally a horde.
Why was it me that had to watch it?
There were actual Minecraft players.
They should not depend on me to watch a corner.
That's so stupid.
Why would you depend on somebody that didn't even know what was going on?
That was trying to sabotage.
Alright.
Let's see.
Let me pull up my stream labels.
I want to thank everybody.
Thank you for the tier 1 sub.
Thank you for the tier 1...
Random VTuber 13.
Thank you for getting a sub to 5.
Okay.
That was good.
Merlin and Crazy.
Thank you for the tier 1 sub.
I'm trying to look at the gifteds right now.
Where are the gifteds?
Oh my god.
Guys, I'm sorry.
My thing doesn't sync.
Where are the gifted settings?
Donation.
Oh no.
Guys, I don't remember how to use my labels.
Oh, here it is.
No, that's not what it is.
I just refreshed it.
Sorry, I'm trying to remember where the gifts are.
Wait, are there no gifts here?
Professional streamers.
Anyway, thank you for all the gifts, guys.
Dragon, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Well, I get to start my rest now.
What a day, though.
Huge shout-out for Twitch.
Thank you for gifting a sub to KekW.
I'm just gonna say a huge shout-out for the invite.
I know I was crying about it.
That I made it this far.
But honestly, we had...
What a ride, though.
What an insane ride we had together.
That was actually crazy.
I don't think any of us expected the game...
expected it to be like this.
Day 3 was actually crazy.
Oh my god.
But yeah, huge shout-out.
Huge shout-out to the invite and for going through this whole whole crazy event.
I lasted all the way to day 4.
I'm proud of myself.
I beat so many pro Minecraft players.
We made it so far.
So yeah, it was fun.
Thank you everybody for watching.
It's finally over.
We have freedom now.
It's finally...
It's finally over.
We're all free.
We can now enjoy resting.
I'm going to go raid Gumi so you can check out the rest of the...
the rest of the journey if she's still alive.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Pause, check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
Bonus ending.
I forgot to chill as always.
If you guys don't know, I stream on YouTube, so check me out there.
Anyone know whenever I stream on Twitch, check, do exclamation point Twitter and follow me on Twitter.
Also, YouTube's reveal, YouTube's figure reveal.
I'm going to tweet about it later.
The YouTube's figure.
Yeah, what else?
If you want to support me via other means, check out my merch.
Thank you guys.
Forgot to chill.
Anyway, bye for real.